here with reaction South Carolina
Senator Lindsey Graham Senator good to
see you let me let me begin tonight with
this um and I did by the way love your
comments that they'll have blood on
their hands what's happening in the
hearing today we just had Josh Holly on
about okay Joe Biden said he's going to
respond there's been nearly 200 attacks
against American Service members in Iraq
and Syria uh this day was inevitable
because Joe didn't lift a finger with
over what 75 attacks he didn't do a
thing except take out an empty Warehouse
so he's embolden Iran the way I see it
you're you're what's your take well
number one you're dead right why did not
why didn't this happen on Trump's watch
Iran was afraid of trump he killed the
head of their revolutionary God uh guard
solaman Biden has yet to hit Iran
directly the Iranians could care less
how many hoodies you kill they could
care less how many Iraqi militia you
killed the only way that will change
your behavior and stop killing Americans
and attacking our troops and trying to
bomb ships in the Red Sea is for Joe
Biden to hit their oil infrastructure
and start killing their soldiers inside
of Iran I'm not asking to invade Iran
but I am calling on President Biden
tonight go to the source of the problem
if you don't hit the Iranian oil
infrastructure and hit them in the
wallet and make them fear you they're
going to keep killing our soldiers to
The Three Families uh who whose loved
one lost her life it breaks my heart
this was all preventable so Mr President
hit Iran and hit them now and hit them
hard to protect Americans In Harm's Way
I don't know if he has it in him I mean
I want to be very clear here because
there's not a single person watching
right now I think I think the American
people's appetite for a long uh
protracted conflict in that area of the
world is probably zero at this point
however when you attack American troops
nearly 200 times and then you kill
American troops to not have a response
at all is unfathomable to me you are
basically then giving them you know free
access to do whatever they want to
American troops there has got to be a
proportional response I like your idea
take out their refineries that is the
that is the biggest source of wealth for
the Iranian mullers I think that's a
simple solution I do too and they would
stop they have four refineries you see
from space uh make sure if they do this
again or do it now they have three and
if they keep doing it they have two and
they will stop they will give in when
they're afraid of America they were
afraid of Donald Trump to the American
people our soldiers are over there to
make sure Isis and al- Qaeda that they
don't come back and hit us here at home
they're there to protect the Homeland
Iran's trying to drive us out of the mid
East Mr President you owe it to those In
Harm's Way to have their back the reason
they're being attacked act so often is
Iran doesn't fear you if you hit Iranian
oil infrastructure and hit them where it
hurts they would stop stop being afraid
of the Ayatollah he should be afraid of
America we've lost DET turret uh in 2021
the Taliban took over Afghanistan in
2022 Russia invaded Ukraine in 2023
Hamas attacked Israel in 2024 they're
attacking ships in the Red
Sea a a
Biden has been a disaster in his first
three years every year a war has
started so the iaea and inspectors
they've actually gone public in saying
Iran now is enriching military grade
uranium that they could probably have a
bomb if not in in a couple of short
weeks now I don't know what the world's
going to look like if if the mullers of
Iran with their radical ideology have
nuclear weapons I'm not sure that
mutually assured destruction would deter
them at all that's a scary thought what
does the region do about this what does
the world need to think about this I was
in Saudi Arabia over the weekend if Iran
gets a bomb they're going to get a bomb
see the IAT would use the bomb to
destroy Israel because he's a religious
Nazi he believes that the missing MTI in
a well the 10th eom will come back to
save the day when there's chaos in the
world he intends to use the weapon for
religious reasons rocket man's trying to
keep his regime uh in survival mode so
here's what I would say uh to the
American people Biden's been in office
three years in 2021 the Taliban take
back Afghanistan 2022 Russia invades
Ukraine 2023 Hamas attacks Israel here's
what's 2024 Iran's going to break out to
a nuclear bomb and it's up to Israel if
we don't do uh more uh to stop Iran
we're going to have a war with Iran in
2024 over their efforts to get a bomb
and watch China they're going after
quote reunification with Taiwan if it's
going to happen I bet it happens this
year lindsy gr thank you Senator
appreciate it hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else